we got Eric in the house what do you got
from you buddy hey Rich how's it going I
like the shirt you're wearing tonight I
got another
um kind of kill the beta question okay I
um divorced I've got young kids and I
ended up in a long-term relationship
with uh a girl that lives an hour and a
half away she is a single mom she's a
single mom and we we see each other
sometimes I see her son sometimes she
visits my kids and sometimes we get them
all together but I've been dating for
about two years for now now and I'm just
wondering kind of how to kill the beta
you know um I've had these like
urges that I want to progress the
relationship forward into something more
and uh with the distance I just I just
don't think that's gonna happen
so so I mean you're probably locked in
your school zone with your kids and
she's going to be locked in her school
zone with her kids anyway right yep no
there's no way that it's gonna it's
gonna work and our kids are young so
it's not how old are you I'm 38. how old
is she 37. do you want to have more kids
probably not
okay so what is the point in you two
living together
there is none no it's it's not and I
know if I logically think about it I'm
like oh this is great we have fun we do
fun things it's a it's a great
relationship
um question is how you know I get every
once in a while I'll get into these kind
of trains where I'm like well this
relationship's not progressing and I'm
like where does it need to progress to I
mean is there really yeah that's just
again that's you know that's plugging in
that's that's just plugging back into
the Matrix and you know believing all
the societal lies the narratives like
okay well you start dating and then you
like each other and then when it comes
to single you know parents that have
kids and you know then they start
thinking okay well then the next step is
let's introduce you to my kids and then
we'll go out with your kids sort of
thing and then maybe we'll take a
vacation together and see how they get
along and then you start thinking okay
should we maybe get a place together
maybe halfway between where we live
right now they like you start cooking up
all this [ __ ] ask me how I know I
dated a single mom right so
what's wrong with the scenario that
you're in absolutely nothing it's
actually a pretty good scenario to be in
because you don't have to combine your
lives I mean you've got a pretty good
reason to maintain your household she
stays at hers you date you have your fun
you don't want to have any more kids
anyway so what's the point in moving in
together like do you want to raise some
other dude's kids she's not going to
want to raise you know some other
woman's kids you know she's going to
want authority over them but she's not
going to want any kind of responsibility
to them did you read my book I talk
about those details about dating is yeah
yeah I was uh dating her before I read
your book yeah but um you know as how
did that hit you by the way like when
you went through that chapter about you
know the truth about dating single moms
yeah it was just you hit the I mean even
what you're talking about right now just
gets a nail right on the head I mean
it's exactly on point you know Eric I
had a conversation with my lawyer a
couple years ago we had lunch and you
know we're shooting the [ __ ] and like in
Toronto we've got the East End and the
West End and he lives in one of the ends
and you know he was saying his
girlfriend lives in the other end
um and I said to him you know so what do
you think life's going to look like you
look look like for you going forward you
just I've just resigned myself to the
fact that I'm going to be a lifelong
bachelor he goes you know I've seen
enough and I've done enough he goes I'm
not having any more kids I'm too old for
that
um I don't see any benefit whatsoever
there's no upside to me blending my life
with another woman's life even if she's
better off than I am um which is
generally not going to happen because
women tend to date across and up on a
socioeconomic scale so generally she's
getting the better guy and he's
generally dating down and she is often
taken care of by the ex-husband money
and resources and child support flows to
sort of equalize things but he just
looked at it like I think I'm just going
to be a lifelong bachelor like there's
no benefit to me whatsoever to blending
my life with some other woman and
complicating things and intertwining
them because if you have to untie that
knot for whatever reason it's just
easier to say see ya I'm out peace bye
Felicia
yeah yeah no the I guess the challenges
I grew up in a household my parents are
very much in love still and you know
they're they're in their mid 70s and
enjoying life together and you know I
that's my model for a marriage and
you know I'm just in a different place
right now and yeah like look man like
how long ago did you get uh divorced
three years ago how old were your kids
uh eight and seven yeah focus on your
kids man because like you've got maybe
till they're 12 ish
um you know before they start not being
that interested in you
um right now they're like that's a great
age that they're they're your best buds
you can do stuff with them on a regular
basis don't put a lot of focus on women
or dating or anything to do with their
kids like invest your time and resources
and what matters and that's in your own
lineage not some other dude's lineage
take care of that
like see how everything sits with you
over that time and if you want to change
anything in the future at least do it
from an informed position where it's
like you know you really know what this
chick's made of you know sort of thing
how long you been dating
uh like two years red flags from my red
flag chapter
besides single mom not not really okay
well I mean I talked about the one
condition in the single mom chapter
where I said it might make sense is that
something that that would apply to you I
mean she she has a younger son so if and
I have a daughter so it somewhat applies
yeah but that's a risk factor though
yeah
so there's so there's really not a lot
of benefit dude like I would just carry
on doing what you're doing if you want
to keep seeing her she's she's cool you
know you guys have a good time then do
it but why do you want to complicate
that unnecessarily things are not going
to get better yeah I don't want to
complicate it and I know and that was
kind of one of the reasons you know I'm
going into the relationship and you know
she lives a hour and a half away I mean
I was like do we want to do a truck
like my role when I'm dating is like 20
minutes that's it like I'm not like I'm
not driving more than 20 minutes yeah
it's interesting it you know there's um
you know there's desire on both sides if
you may you know you have to make that
drive round trip you know it's
it's 90 minutes each way yeah okay so
three hours of driving to go out and see
her and then come back if you know
you're not spending the night yeah it's
mostly over overnight stuff it's only I
mean it's the weekends we don't have our
kids most of the time so
everything's good otherwise self-care
you know money's right you're like you
got yeah money's right I've been you
know it's a millionaire no not not yet
but I have a I have a good job and I I
work hard I work out I mean things are
good I have great relationship with my
kids and I put that that's my number one
priority I you know I just you know I
struggle with the loss of not not my
ex-wife just the the family you know I I
I'm a beta for family so for sure and I
trying to unplug from that a little bit
as well nothing wrong with it
yeah there's nothing wrong with family
you know family's a wonderful thing but
it's a traditional deal is what I'm
saying yeah yeah look I I get it but I
mean like even if you were to replace
your ex-wife with the new girlfriend
you know you fully know that it's not
it's not even going to be close and on a
balance of probabilities the chances of
things ending up the way that your
marriage ended up are more likely than
things going very well
yeah right so it's like girlfriend's
overwatched for sure
girlfriends are better than wives so why
would you want to turn a girlfriend into
a life basically because as soon as you
live together that's the way the
government views things
yeah yeah well I appreciate it rich all
right man as always your advice is spot
on thanks buddy take care hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out